[Música]
había una vez
en un lugar del sur un pueblo donde lo
imposible se hizo posible
donde la utopía se hizo realidad como
ocurrió esta magia
esto sucedió porque a los habitantes de
este pueblo les desconectaron el cable
citó de los prejuicios y todos se veían
simplemente como el prójimo que hay que
amar por sobre todas las cosas
ustedes creen que esto es posible
confiarían la educación de sus hijos en
alguien que se viera como yo
díganme si alguna vez alguno de ustedes
no tuvo que cortarse el pelo para
parecer más inteligente o ponerse un
traje para verse más profesional
este cuento que empecé a contarles no es
un cuento es una historia y es real pasa
en una escuela pública que hoy cuenta
con dos mil setecientos alumnos 1500 son
del nivel secundario
porque le eligen y quienes le eligen
le elige sobre todo aquel que necesita
una segunda oportunidad
el que quedó excluido
por haber repetido por haber abandonado
o a veces por adaptarse a las normas de
convivencia
esta escuela que recibe a todos
porque sabemos
que ya es demasiado el dolor que hay
afuera
dolor del hambre dolor del abandono
dolor de la discriminación
esta es mi escuela con su diversidad
hermosa y única
la provincia argentina de la que vengo
tiene un estado que se anima a innovar
pero innovar de verdad no desde papeles
de escritorio fomenta verdaderos cambios
y en la búsqueda de la mejora de la
calidad educativa se crearon en el año
unas escuelas que se llaman de
autogestión estas escuelas fueron
tomados del modelo de eeuu las escuelas
chárter con la diferencia que las
escuelas de la provincia de san luís
siempre están subvencionadas por el
estado
cuál es la obligación es la innovación y
el propósito es que sean establecidas en
los lugares más vulnerables
es una gran estrategia de
descentralización que parece un detalle
pequeño pero tener el recurso a la mano
para proponer proyectos significativos
teniendo en cuenta el contexto y que
sean hechos rápidamente para que llegue
a quien necesita
ha sido una gran estrategia
pero bueno a veces las cosas no salen
como se piensan o a veces hay gente que
no entiende la consigna y pasó hace unos
años atrás que en el nivel secundario de
esta escuela
se confundió
calidad educativa con corte de pelo
calidad educativa con uniforme y no es
que estemos en contra de eso es que
estamos hablando de sectores vulnerables
y si le exigimos algo que no pueden dar
genera violencia y fue así que se generó
muchísima violencia los chicos estaban
todos enojados en ese momento eran 300
los alumnos del nivel secundario muy
enojados enojado los padres enojados los
profesores enojados la directora era un
caos
yo estaba a cargo del nivel primario y
veía con mucha tristeza eso que pasaba
con nuestros jóvenes que habían sido
nuestros alumnos
pero no tenía mucho por hacer
llega un momento de tanto caos que
intervino el ministerio de educación
y en esa intervención me dice
señora catalán necesito que usted se
haga cargo el nivel secundario mi
primera sensación fue salir corriendo
pero
los docentes nos conocemos
no sabemos decir que no sobre todo
cuando se trata
de poder cambiar algo que no nos gusta y
de hacer algo por esos chicos que fueron
nuestros son nuestros y serán nuestros
así que decidí dar un día de un día para
el otro pasé de ser directora del nivel
primario a ser directora del nivel
secundario con 300 jóvenes totalmente
enojados y si ya más nada que perder
cuanta tarea teníamos por delante yo
siempre digo que cambios o que uno jamás
está solo en la vida
y siempre le voy a agradecer a todo mi
equipo el que me acompañó y el que me
acompaña ahora porque entre todos es
mejor
y salen las cosas mejor
y así fue que teníamos que pensar que
hacíamos con ese lío que teníamos
lo primero fue escucharnos
escuchar a los jóvenes que querían para
ellos asambleas por la no-violencia y
escuchar a los profesores que también
tenían algo para decir había que
encontrar
el interés
de los jóvenes y de los profesores
y buscar un punto en común para poder
convivir
entre las reuniones que tenía con el
personal
les les digo que siempre siempre
llegábamos al mismo lugar terminábamos
discutiendo por el uniforme por el pelo
por el piercing
yo en ese momento me tuve que parar
y pensar
y les pido que piensen conmigo
cuando un niño o un joven
entra por la puerta de la escuela
qué es más importante
lo que trae puesto
o el alma de ese niño y de ese joven que
viene en busca de una oportunidad y de
contención
saben que nosotros nos quedamos con el
alma
y así empezó una gran tarea que era
concientizar nos todos para cambiar
tuvo seis estructuras de pensamiento que
tenemos que a veces nos dejan en el
tiempo
fue así que empezamos con muchísima
capacitación sabíamos poco había mucho
mucho desacuerdo
entre esas capacitaciones conocimos un
pedagogo español que yo se los
recomiendo que lo escuchen se llama el
doctor miguel ángel santos guerra y él
se convertiría en el padrino de la
escuela después y entre muchas de las
cosas que nos enseñó
les voy a contar cuál fue la primera
frase que me impactó
y él dijo ah sí
si tú
quieres enseñarle matemática juancito
debes saber más de juancito que de
matemática
el vínculo
el vínculo es
es necesario y es fundamental en el
proceso de enseñanza-aprendizaje
ya estábamos mejor estábamos mucho mejor
ya habíamos pasado la crisis del aspecto
pero empezamos a encontrar otros motivos
que generaron mucho malestar
materias previas no sé si acá se llaman
de la misma manera las materias que no
aprobamos y quedan para el año siguiente
la repitencia el abandono
que todo esto lleva al abandono
escuchamos un relato y yo lo voy a
compartir con ustedes seguramente no lo
van a olvidar nunca más
en un pueblo había un pescador decidió
tomar sus cosas un domingo y salir
se instaló a la orilla del río el río
era muy caudaloso
y en eso que estaba muy tranquilo
pescando
de que viene una persona ayudándose por
el río
entonces por supuesto su solidaridad
humanidad busco una soga tira los saca
del agua y no termina de pasar eso que
viene otra persona ahogándose y otra y
otra y otra y otra más y se acaba nos
acaban gente del agua y que lo que
estaba pasando
entonces el pescador con sentido común
dijo vamos a ir río arriba a ver qué
está pasando porque la gente se cae al
agua y con que se encontró
con que había un puente roto
y decidieron reparar el puente para que
la gente dejara de caerse al agua
tal
como ese pescador
esta escuela decidió ir río arriba y ver
cuál era el puente roto que hacía que
tantos chicos no terminaron el
secundario las estadísticas son fatales
por lo menos en argentina
teníamos que reparar el puente
que pensamos pensamos en un proyecto
sumamente ambicioso se llama proyecto
cero que pretendía proyecto zero zero
repitencia cero materias previas cero
deserción escolar cero sobre edad cero
bullying
era una utopía
sí
pero la verdad es que la realidad nos
parecía increíble
y así fue que esta escuela con esos 300
alumnos pasaron a ser 1500 alumnos y hoy
tenemos 0 repitencia 0 materias previas
0 deserción escolar al menos no por
causas de la escuela cero sobre edad
y cero bullying habíamos reparado el
puente
pero ya no nos bastaba con eso
queríamos una escuela feliz
entonces tuvimos que repensar sentarnos
y pensar
que era escuela
qué es ser profesor
qué es ser alumno
que queríamos para nuestros alumnos y
decidimos que queríamos
queríamos que encontraron aquello en lo
que son buenos
quería que encontraron su talento
para ello tuvimos que ofrecerle un
abanico y le ofrecemos un abanico de
posibilidades
arte deporte radio
diario un montón de talleres talleres de
oficios más lo que curricularmente
también trabajamos todos los días
fue así
en este abanico de posibilidades todos
los días los veíamos con una sonrisa en
la cara y yo digo no importa cuál es la
estrategia
puede ser la que a ustedes se les ocurra
lo que nunca nunca puede faltar es el
amor que es el ingrediente indispensable
para la vida
había un doctor argentino que
seguramente lo han escuchado nombrar
y se llamaba rené favaloro
él no podía imaginarse una medicina sin
humanidad
pueden imaginarse usted es una educación
sin humanidad
hace poco transitando los pasillos de la
escuela vi algo que es muy común es
cotidiano pasa todos los días pero a mí
sinceramente no deja de conmover me
había una profesora dictando su clase
con un bebé en brazos y ese bebé
la mamá de ese bebé estaba dentro de su
alumnado
escuchando a esa profesora que dejaba de
ser solo una profesora para convertirse
en una cómplice de su sueño que era
terminar el secundario para encontrar
una vida mejor para ella y para su hija
y ahí entendí que la mirada puesta en lo
que sí se puede siempre es mejor porque
siempre hace bien
la cara de los jóvenes cuando te miran y
te dicen
profe porque quieres ayudarme
como no lo vamos a hacer
les quiero presentar a eso natalia y
octavio
elegí la escuela porque me aceptaron de
la manera en la que vengo o sea con los
tatuajes piercings y además lo
necesitaron también por la edad que
tengo porque ya estaba
como el sobriedad pero en otras
instituciones la escuela me contuvo
dentro y fuera de la institución me
contuvo primero cuando yo quedé
embarazada elegí esta escuela por un
tema judicial porque
en otros lados en otras escuelas no
no podía entrar también me apoyaron
mucho cuando con el fallecimiento a mi
mamá estuvieron en todo momento
gracias
[Música]
hagamos escuelas vivas que alienten y
esperen la educación es un derecho y es
para todos
y es posible que a todos les vaya bien
hagamos escuelas reales donde reine la
utopía de que si se puede y el que todos
pueden
muchas gracias pura vida costa rica
[Música]